on that topic by the way
as a small side note i tweeted emacs is
greater than vim
yesterday and deleted deleted the tweet
10 minutes later when i realized you're
you were honest i
started a war yeah i was like oh i was
just kidding
i i was just being um walk walk
walk back so people still feel
passionately about that particular piece
of uh
i don't get that because emacs is
clearly so much better i don't
understand
but you know why do i say that because i
cuz like i spent a block of time
in the 80s um making my fingers know
the emacs keys and now like that's part
of the thought process for me
like i need to express and if you take
that if you take my emacs key bindings
away
i become
yep i can't express myself i'm the same
way with the i don't know if you know
what it is but it's a kinesis keyboard
which is uh this
butt shaped keyboard yes i've seen them
yeah and
they're very uh i don't know sexy
elegant yeah they're
just beautiful yeah they're they're
gorgeous uh way too expensive
but uh the the problem with them similar
with emacs
is when once you learn to use it
it's harder to use other things it's
hard to use other things there's this
absurd thing where i have like
small elegant lightweight beautiful
little laptops
and i'm sitting there in a coffee shop
with a giant kinesis keyboard
and a sexy little laptop it's absurd but
it you know like i used to feel bad
about it but at the same time you just
kind of have to
sometimes it's back to the billy joel
thing you just have to throw that billy
joe record and
throw taylor swift and justin bieber to
the wind
so see but i like them now because i
because again i have no musical taste
like
like now that i've heard justin bieber
enough i'm like i really like his songs
and
taylor swift not only do i like her
songs but my daughter's convinced that
she's a genius and so now i basically
have i'm signed on to that so
so yeah that that speaks to the back to
the robustness of the human brain that
speaks to the neuroplasticity that you
can just
you can you can just like a mouse teach
yourself to
a problem dog teach yourself to enjoy
taylor swift i'll try it out
i don't know i try you know what it
has to do with just like acclimation
right just like you said a couple weeks
yeah that's an interesting experiment
i'll actually try that like that wasn't
the intent of the experiment just like
social media it wasn't intended as an
experiment to see what we can take as a
society
but it turned out that way i don't think
i'll be the same person on the other
side of the week
listening to taylor swift but let's try
it's more compartmental
don't be so worried like it's like i get
that you can be worried but don't be so
worried because we compartmentalize
really well and so
it won't bleed into other parts of your
life you won't start i don't know
wearing red lipstick or whatever like
it's it's fine it's changed fashion and
everything
it's funny but you know what the the
thing you have to watch out for is
you'll walk into a coffee shop once we
can do that again
and recognize the song and you'll be no
you won't know that you're singing along
until everybody in the coffee shop is
looking at you and then you're like
that wasn't me yeah that's the
you know people are afraid of agi i'm
afraid of the taylor uh
the taylor swift takeover
you